abone ol
ilk
[Alkış]
öncelikle okuldan kız olsun istiyorum
Gerçekten o Kars akıllı görüntü
kalabalık olacağını tahmin etmiyordum
çok şanslısınız çok şanslıyız bu kadar
güzel bir ortam bizlere sağladığı için
sizlerin yaşındayken benim böyle şansım
yoktu Aslında güzel ya da kötü
tecrübeler evde edilen kişileri
dinleyebileceğim onları ulaşabileceğim
konuşmama başlamadan önce kendini
tanımak isterim beni tanımayanlar için
ismimi Duygu beni bunu kurucu ortağı
adresi yazıyorum 3000000 fazla diye bir
ailede bunu Platformu ve her şey tam
altı buçuk sene önce başladı bugün
konunun TEMA'nın kırılmalar olduğunu
öğrendiğinde açıkcası çok sevindim ve on
hayatımı süzmeye başladı de hayatımdaki
kırılma noktaları nelerdir bunu bir
içinde okula giderken işe giderken
düşünüyorsunuz Benim kızıma nokta acaba
neydi diye ama aslında bunu düşünmeye
başladığınızda o kadar fazla al his
duygu olduğunu fark ediyorsunuz ki klima
yaşadığımız ne kadar çok mutluyum
bunları hiç yazmam lazım Çünkü 80
yaşında hatırlayabilirim
gitmeye başladım nerede başlamıştı Benim
Babam emekli subay Marmaris'e Times
çıkmıştı babam görev yaparken o zamanlar
ve ben ortaokula ve Pardon ilk
okuldaydım ve hala Denize girmeyi
yüzmeyi bilmiyor mu başlarda ve
kolluksuz içine bilemiyorum uyandığımda
utanıyordum bayağı geç kalmışım yazdığım
için hem arkadaşını düşünebiliyor
musunuz oradaki herkes denize gidiyor ve
o gün ve
babamın arkadaşının minik
ayı denize açılmıştı koltukların vardı
Babam bugün bana dedi ki bu kollukları
çıkarıp Birazdan seni atacağım o suya
burada çok dedim değil tabii ki ve sen
üzüleceksin bunu öğreneceksin bunu
açacağız artık her zaman hayatta sizi
tren aslında bir güç örüyorum Neden
Çünkü belki işte bir yerde
yapabileceğinizi biliyorsunuz ama bunu
yapabilmek için birilerinin orada
olduğunu sizi koruyacağım hissetmek
istiyorsunuz Aslında bu çocuklukta
yaşadığı ve burada o günden sonra çok
iyi bir yüzde oldum Hatta profesyonel
yüzümü dönemlerde oldu Ya aslında bu
ve en baştan iş hayatındaki her güne
kadar yaşadığınız bir şey var beni bu
hikaye dönecek olursak en büyük kırılmam
da yine çok benzer bir hikayeydi
2015 yazıyor
Evet şu anki eşim o zaman ki erkek
arkadaşınla
tatildeyiz daha iki üç aydır beraberiz
çok yeri ve O Yaz ilk defa
11n
senelerce içinde tuttu bu iş fikri
anlattım Bunu anlattığımda açıkcası
tamamen böyle bir masada sohbet ediyoruz
Çok keyifli bir ortam hatta biraz daha
detaylı diye tavla oynuyoruz birşeyler
içiyoruz üzerinde o gün giydiğinde Siz
kendinizi ki ilgili çok iyi hatırlıyorum
öylesine anlattım Normalde burada
İnsanlara çok iş fikirleri anlatan bir
insanım aslında bu benim çok
derinlerimde diğer de hem kendimi
aradığın bulmaya çalıştım birşeymiş
Belki de be ve anlatamam anlatmasammı
çıkacağım şimdi ama diyorum ki bir anda
fethederiz nereye kaçabilir ki anlatmam
gerek de
daha sonra paylaştım ve dedi ki bana bu
önceden nasıl Hani yapılmamış Türkiye'de
olmadığına emin misin yurtdışında var mı
O biraz konuştuk o kadar daha yeni
Beraber olduğumuz için gerçek faktörleri
hayata bu fikri geçirilmeye işimin
anlatamadım onu neden anlatamadım çünkü
şunu da ikisi ararım şu benim için senin
söylediğin kadar kolay değil bunu
yapabilmek Ben ben o zamanlar 10 senedir
yaklaşık kurumsal ayakta çalışıyordum
marka yönetimi yapıyordum ve kazandığım
belli bir limiti birikim var belli bir
maaş var aldığım kararı ben onu bırakıp
nasıl yaşayacağım seninle bir daha böyle
bir tatil nasıl gelebileceğim diyemedim
Vega adam kaçmasın
kaçmamız şakası bir yana o gün içinde
konuşan Obur yapamazsın diyen bir idare
faktörü sıralayan duyguyu susturdum
ufaklık bunların Ben bunu yapamıyorum
döndük Bu arada tabi olay sadece sen
bana o gün araştırırken yurtdışında
bunun benzeri yapmış birini gösterdi onu
bunu gel beraber saatlerce bakarken ve
gördüğüm anda inanıp bakın bir şaka
yapmıyorum şuradan başlayıp beynime
kadar çıkan bir zehirlenme yaşadım Sanki
yarın sabah adamlar bavulları da
gelecekler benim hayalim olan düşündüm
Benim de Bir şifreyi yapacaklar bu
döndüm babamı anlatsam Tabii baba çok
kumsalda başarılı giden bir kariyer
varken sadece şunu dedi Ben diyorum ki
büyük veri işte 3 mutlu o zaman
düşünüyorum video olabileceği diğer
veriyi doğru işlemek markalara kazanç
sağlamak avantaj sağlama doğru kişiyle
doğru yönü buluşturmak altın babacığım
dedi ki sende varsa ben sana ve desteğin
arkandayım
ve benim benim bunun seveni böyle
başladı en büyük hay her yıl Muharrem
bir tanesi Aslında o gün o masada
fikrini Hayatında ilk defa bir insanı
anlattığında İçimdeki sesi susturmak
tıbbi tabii ki o yoldüzü oldu müzikle
şöyle ilik bensiz ben bir şimdi
olduğunda bana
girişimci olan ve vermiyor Bu kadar
Aslında sektör ilerlemiş verdiğinden bir
tanım Hiç ben de girişimci olduğunu
biliyorum İçinde bir gibi bana iş
kurmaya ve itiyordu ve
bu yolun yokuş olacağını biliyordum ama
bu kadar yapılacağını bilmiyorum ve
Aslında Her gününüz ayrı bir kırılmayla
geçiyor
Biz Bu Yola çıktık başladık işte 8 9A
kadar beni bunu you diğer kuruculuktan
yazılımı yapan arkadaşımla yazmaya
başlıyoruz ben tabi çok az birikimin var
Babamın Samsun destek olduğu bana o
dönem ve bir an önce satış yapmak ürünü
çıkarmak istiyoruz biz hayata
tutunabilmek için maddi ve manevi Ama
tabii ki hiçbir zaman planlı istediğiniz
gibi hızlı ilerlemiyor ve
bir gün yine hikayenin öbeğinde sevgili
babam var Yemek yiyoruz Babam bana dedi
ki Duygu ürün ne zaman çıkacak ne zaman
satış yapabileceksin Hani ayırdığımız
metre şeyimiz bitti yok yapacağız acaba
kurum Sana dönsem Ben o an böyle sanki
birçok yazıyla hiç yaşamadım Umarım
yaşam onu
bir vurulmuş gibi hissettim kendi Ben
haklıydı sorgusunda bir daha dönemde
abone ol
ya o yüzden o saniye bunu artık yapmak
zorundaydı ve
ve o gün Aslında Biriyle tanıştım
çalıştığım kişi
kabuğumu ki ilk defa kırdığı için de
dinlerdeki duyguydu size çok her yerde
Aslında paylaşmadım şey paylaşmak
istiyorum şimdi
Sağ ol telefonu salata çalışan Duygu
nasıl bir kızdı başarılı mıydı terfiler
aldı mı diye sorarsanız
bana kalsa da bir Güven başarılı o zaman
var ama şu anda 33 yaşındaki Duygu
olarak bu söyleyebilirim ki ben o
dünyada o dönemde Bence hiç de başarılı
değil mişiz ben kendi yolumu Beni
bununla bulduğum gün içinde Derinlerdeki
başka ki duyguyla tanıştık ve bu benim
için çok kıymetliydi o Duygu Eskiden
olmasına çalıştı Kumsal ayakta 10 dakika
daha uyuyabilmek için acaba geçimin
zamanında işe en kötü 10 dakika Biz
kalsam şöyle derim Yani duygu değil
günde 17-18 saat neredeyse aşka çalışan
bir duygu oldu Evet çok yorucu ama
dünyanın en keyifli şeyi keyfi olan şey
en iyi denilebilecek bir girişim
kurulmuş olmak değil kendinizin en iyi
versiyonuyla konuşabilme şansını
yakalamış olmamız Bu da aslında Bu
bahsettiğin kırılmalarda ki en önemli
nokta kendi kabuğu görmek Şimdi kabuğu
kabukları kırabilmek hasta Her gün
farklı başladığımız arttırıyoruz
kabuğunu kurmak ne demek
içinizdeki potansiyeli keşfedeceğiz
bu yöntemi bulabilmek olumsuz bir
durumdan çıkabilmek
var ama düşünürsek için burada çok Yaş
farkımız Elbette var ama çok temel basit
bir ortak noktamız var sizde ne O hasta
hepimiz bu hayatta kabuğu muzu kırarak
gelmek istiyorum dokuz ay hepimiz
annemizin karnında zaman geçirdik en
güvenilir belki hatırlama uzun için
değil En mutlu olduğumuz günlerde belki
ama ne oldu oradan çıkmamız gerekir
burada kalabilir miydi orada kalamazdım
büyümemiz gelişmemiz için ben şunu
söylüyorum yaptığım konuşmalarda
arkadaşlarına sohbetlerde
Aslında
değişim kaçınılmaz olursa kesin hepimiz
her gün değişiyoruz bugün
12 yan yana oturan İnsan değerini çok
iyi arkadaş onun sene sonra da en yakın
arkadaş olabilmenin sırrı ne biliyor
musunuz birlikte benzer günlerde
değişebilme birbirimize her zaman
tamamlayıcı olabiliriz Ben örneğini
şimdi Sekiz senedir beraber ve neredeyse
senedir her sene başka başka Kişiydik ve
birbirimize hep tamamladık işinize böyle
derinizdeki Siz de böyle
ne dedik Anne karnından çıkmak ilk
kabuğu kırma hayatımızda kabuklarını
kırmızı engel olacak tek bir şey var O
da kendiniz O yüzden benim en azından
kısa diyebileceğim 33 senelik hayatında
ki bunun bilinçli olduğumu 25 tanesi
düşünülürse
teknolojinin tavsiye kabımıza kırmak
takip et yengen kendi hiç sesiniz bunu
suya bakmıyor benim size ölürüm
duymamazlıktan geldim kendi
sebepleriniz eski üzerinize bahanelerin
izi çünkü en çok ilk kendimize Bu
anlamda s çekiyoruz burada benim
seversen Süreci en önemli en kıymetli
önerip tavsiye
sadece yapmak istediğinizi odaklanınca
şurada içeride bir şey değer ne
istiyorsa onu yapmak için elimden gelen
şey yapılmış Çünkü o tanışmayı
beklediğimiz sizin birileri daha mutlu
daha güzel versiyonunuz olacağına Ben
Kanlı canlı yönlü olarak kendimi adına
bugünkü Duygu önceki Duygu olarak zıt
kendimi referans göstermek istedim
hepinizin yolu açık olsun beni
dinlediğiniz için teşekkür ederim Şu
[Alkış]